hello everyone and welcome back to the
bullet Chess Championship semi-finals
where alireza firoz just defeated none
other than Magnus Carlsen it was a
brutal match and he defeated him with a
with a three-point margin I believe the
final result was something like let me
just check real quickly uh 14 and a half
to 11 and a half uh probably all I mean
everyone already saw it so that's why
I'm mentioning it and I decided to show
you one game where a brilliant brilliant
tactic was played by uh by alireza and
even though this is bullet this is one
plus zero bullet the players played so
fast and such uh incredibly precise
moves that they basically up until the
point uh where the mistake was made both
of them played with a hundred percent
accuracy pretty much like every move was
a top engine move uh Magnus made a
little mistake and all it is punished
him in uh without even blinking he he
immediately punished him so it was
incredible I will use this uh point in
time as I pause the video moment where
you guys will be able to solve the
position because it's just incredible
that such a thing can happen one minute
sounds like a very little time if you're
not used to playing bullet games online
but to these monsters these you know
epic beasts it is they did not even use
half the time for this game so let's
check it out Magnus has the white pieces
and he opens with Ponte E4 we have Ponte
E5 Knight F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to
B5 Nuru Lopez is on the board upon the
A6 morphe's defense and Bishop to A4 and
here at Knight to F6 uh we have Pawn to
D3 and now Pawn to D6 the Anderson
variation against morphe's defense for
those of you who have followed the Paul
morphy Saga you of course remember the
legendary Anderson versus morphe match
where the uh line was
deployed C3 we have Bishop t7 Castles by
both players and now Rook D1 so these
are all very well known moves of course
both of them notice Rook T8 and 9 beat
the D2 and now all right the absolute
top move here is Bishop to f8 and
whenever we had this position on the
channel I believe Bishop to f8 was
played in 100 of games that I've shown
on the channel from this position but
Prague he goes for Pawn to H6 and there
are only a handful of games that reach
this position uh so uh chances are
Magnus doesn't know it but okay let's
see how Magnus continues Knight to F1
the pretty standard stuff the Knight is
coming to G3 uh but Pawn to B5 chases
away the bishop and there is one game
where Bishop to B3 was played but Magnus
plays Bishop to C2 and it is now as of
move 11 that we have a completely new
game so Bishop back to f8 you know that
this is the square where the bishop
belongs now it's uh helping out with the
defense of the king side and also the
Rook gets full control over the E file
with Knight to G3 Pawn to D5 alireza
strikes in the center A4 a flanker tank
and now Pawn to B4 we have Pawn to A5
and now Bishop to E6 so just standard
developing moves with Bishop to A4 now
as the Knight is on undefended Bishop
back to D7 uh Magnus says you cannot
grab that much activity with your Bishop
bring it back a square e captures on D5
Knight captures and Bishop to D2 We have
B captures in C3 B captures and now
Bishop to D6 so both players as usual
putting pieces on optimal squares Pawn
to H3 and now Knight back to F6 we have
Knights the E4 Knight captures an E4
Rook captures and now Knight back to B8
offering a trade of Bishops but Magnus
decides against the bishop to B3 puts
pressure on this diagonal and Bishop to
F5 now attacks The Rook end if you go
too far back and then you will lose the
D3 Pawn so real cast that we played to
E3 and now Knight to D7 all it is it
just continuous development the Knight
is coming to F6 and the bishop to C4
helping out with the defense of the D3
Pawn you don't have to worry as uh
alireza does not have a beep on or a d
Pawn to kick away the Bishop from C4 so
Knight to F6 and now Queen to E2 just
putting more pressure on that E5 Pawn so
all it is Advanced set point to E4 and
now Knights the D4 are taking the uh you
know full control of the square Left
Behind uh attacking the bishop on F5
Bishop to G6 and now roof the E1
tripling up on the E file and here oh
there is I could just win the exchange
with Bishop to F4 The Rook has nowhere
to go but he finds a very very tricky
move which Magnus Falls for he plays e
captures on D3 and now you'd expect uh
well you'd expect a lot of things but
this is bullet uh Rook captures an E8 is
the way to go Queen captures uh now the
queen trade happens Knight captures and
okay there's the pass Pawn on D3 but
later on you can probably just pick it
up with a rook lift and Bishop captures
on D3 however after he captures on D3
Magnus fell for it he played Bishop
captures on D3 and now alireza actually
immediately played the moves played
within two seconds but uh you know you
try to find it it's a very very cool uh
winning move feel free to pause the
video and win the game for alireza while
I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that
magnus's Queen is hanging that's a weird
thing to say as the queen is oh I mean
so deep in White's camp but it's true
what are you gonna do uh and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is a rook captures on E3 this is what
wins the queen incredible as it is
because it doesn't matter how you
recapture Magnus played Bishop captures
on E3 and now comes Bishop captures on
D3 Queen captures on D3 and pawn to C5
and that's it okay you don't actually
lose the queen you have to give up the
Knight because after you move the Knight
Bishop to H2 check just wins the
undefended queen on D3 so of course
Magnus realized that now after C5 was
played he has no more moves he could
just resign here he played Bishop
captures on H6 hoping that okay maybe
all it is and now captures the Knight
and then he plays Bishop to G5 and he
has at least some uh you know motive to
continue the game but all it is just
captured the free bishop and the the
position remains I mean I still cannot
move if you move the Knight Bishop page
to check still wins the queen so Magnus
will be down two pieces if you continue
the game and yeah like I said a Magnus
spent some 22 seconds for this game
while it is a spent 20 seconds with you
know finding the winning move within the
two seconds so that's how strong these
guys are they did not they didn't even
spend half the time of the one minute
that they have uh Magnus made one
mistake oh it is I took advantage of it
and he just completely crushed Magnus
and later on okay
um uh before the final three games the
result was equal but then there is a uh
one uh three final games that they
played and he uh he took the match
magnets now goes into the loser section
but he can still bounce back and you
know win the entire thing if he starts
playing well and Hikaru is now facing
Daniel naroditski which will also be an
epic match and alireza will face whoever
wins of the two of them uh in the final
so yeah Magnus said in an interview
after the game that okay he had some
problems he has like I don't know if his
end is broken or bruised but he has some
problems with his hand that he uses the
uh play uh so you know and he also had a
a bad Mouse his internet connection was
also bad so he had a lot of things
working against him uh but he didn't uh
you know use that as an excuse uh he
just uh you know mentioned that as they
did ask him you know what was happening
uh but he said that alireza was playing
incredibly well and the Magnus also says
that he in this control one plus zero
that he feels like an underdog against
the top two guys he didn't say who the
top two guys were probably he was
talking to alireza and well either
Hikaru or naroditski now you guys can
decide on that but yeah as you can see
all it is also said that for preparation
for this match against Magnus he just
checked a few openings half an hour
before the games uh and he just you know
crushed Magnus Carlsen so what do you
guys say the chosen one or not uh so
yeah once again really hope you enjoyed
it this is one of the games that I
thought was fun because of this winning
tactic how all it is it just exploded in
two seconds hope you enjoyed that I
would like to thank James Eugene Cashman
Rod Hill Gage wedland Gary chomuk and
the ustaparak for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World such as this wonderful
bullet Chess Championship uh thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day